is it a bird is it a plane no it's a car
just not in the conventional sense
the aeromobil flying roadster is the
closest anyone's come to making a
vehicle made for road and sky it runs on
petrol so fill it up at the gas station
it's about the same length as a luxury
saloon so you can park it on the street
hits the top road speed of 124 miles per
hour so it's no slouch and in the air
has a range of 430 miles oh yeah did I
mention it can fly traffic jams could
still be a problem though the flying
roadster needs at least 200 meters of
clear Road to take off however
regulations may stop this car from
getting airborne in the US and Europe
the prototype couldn't fly in Austria
this week due to aviation rules but
those behind it have identified China
Australia and the Middle East as
potential first markets and while you
can still only imagine owning the
prototype the designers hope to start
manufacturing them in the next couple of
years
estimated price just over 280 thousand
dollars